.
In dieser Sendung
geht es um den Körper
und um die Beziehung,
die wir zum Körper haben.
Früher brauchte man den Körper
v.a. zum Arbeiten,
aber jetzt ist er so etwas
wie eine Visitenkarte.
Was nehmen Menschen
alles für ihren Körper auf sich,
und was ist, wenn der Körper
überhaupt nicht der Norm entspricht?
Das will ich herausfinden.
Ich bin dick und Künstlerin.
Ist halt so.
* Klicken *
Das Bild muss perfekt sein.
"Hallo, Magersucht. Du hast meine
letzten Jahre komplett zerstört."
Ja, ich bin fett. Ich setze mich
für dicke, fette Menschen ein.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich steige in diesen Keller,
weil hier unten ein Privat-Gym
für Bodybuilderinnen
und Bodybuilder ist.
Was die mit ihrem Körper machen,
sehen wir jetzt gleich.
Entschuldigt, darf ich euch
schnell stören? Ich bin Mona.
Rahel.
- Rahel, hallo.
Melissa. Freut mich.
- Venesa.
Freut mich sehr.
Was macht ihr gerade?
Wir üben gerade Posing.
Wie ihr euch präsentieren müsst?
- Genau.
Genau. Die Bühnenpräsenz, die
Pflichtposen, die man zeigen muss.
Ich glaube,
ich schaue euch einfach mal zu.
Musst du jetzt alles anspannen?
- Ja.
Es soll entspannt aussehen,
aber man ist total angespannt.
In der Figurenklasse geht es darum,
hier eine schöne V-Form zu haben.
Man muss auch die Beine
schön präsentieren können.
Das sind die Übergänge.
Ich finde,
dabei kann man die Muskulatur,
oder die eigenen Stärken, zeigen.
Man kann auch
die Hüften rausstrecken.
Dann geht man
in die nächste Pose über.
Hast du schon mal etwas gewonnen?
- Ja, also ...
Ich habe schon
in allen Kategorien gewonnen.
Schweizermeisterschaften?
- Das war eine Weltmeisterschaft.
In welcher Klasse hast du gewonnen?
- Bodybuilding und Figurenklasse.
In beiden?
An einer Weltmeisterschaft?
Ja.
- An deinem ersten Wettkampf?
Wow. Okay.
Hier sieht man, dass Definition
nochmals etwas anderes ist.
Wow. Sorry. Aber das ist so krass.
Nervt es dich,
wenn Leute so reagieren wie ich?
Wenn sie finden: "Wow, unglaublich!"
Eigentlich ist es eine Bestätigung,
dass man etwas richtig gemacht hat.
Man möchte auf der Bühne
doch erreichen, dass alle denken:
"Wow, die hat etwas geleistet."
Wenn du dich hier anschaust,
was denkst du?
Es ist recht heftig.
Wenn ich die Bilder anschaue,
denke ich: "Wow, krass!"
Ich sehe mich eigentlich meistens
mit mehr Körperfett.
Erst, wenn man
in der Diätphase ist, sieht man,
was drunter steckt.
Das ist kein Zustand,
den man lange halten kann.
Wie viel Körperfett
hast du hier noch?
Schwierig.
Unter 10 % liegt es bestimmt.
Ich tendiere zu 6-7 % Körperfett.
Fast nichts mehr.
Ab wann wird es gefährlich? Ab 5 %?
Bei Frauen schon früher.
Die letzten zwei, drei, vier Wochen
vor dem Wettkampf sind nicht gesund.
Das empfehle ich auch niemandem.
Das ist nicht jedermanns Sache.
Auch das mental durchstehen.
Es ist auch speziell.
Man sieht kraftvoll aus.
Nichts als Muskeln, aber man kann
eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Ja. Okay.
Findest du es trotzdem schön,
obwohl du weisst,
dass das kein gesunder Körper ist?
Wenn ich entscheiden müsste,
was ich am schönsten finde,
wäre es etwas dazwischen.
Wie viele Tage pro Woche
trainierst du, und wie lange?
Das ist unterschiedlich.
In der Regel sicher fünfmal.
Pro Woche?
- Genau.
Wie lange?
- Bestimmt 2 Std.
Das zieht sich jeweils
schon in die Länge. Ja.
Okay. Wow.
Trackst du alles, was du isst?
- Ja.
Jedes Essen ist genau kontrolliert.
Du weisst, was du wann isst,
wie viele Kalorien es hat.
Du kannst dir nie am Kiosk
einen Schokoriegel kaufen?
Nein. Man gestaltet
seine Mahlzeiten so,
dass man davon
möglichst viel profitieren kann.
Schokoriegel sind kontraproduktiv.
- Aber fein.
Aber in dem Sinn kontraproduktiv.
Dein Leben ist nach dem Rhythmus
des Bodybuildings strukturiert.
Ja, das ist so.
- Mich fragt selten jemand:
"Was machst du heute Abend?"
Ins Gym, natürlich.
Das Schwierigste
scheinen mir eure Schuhe.
Weshalb diese Schuhe?
Wenn eine Frau hohe Schuhe trägt,
scheint sie sehr weiblich.
Man präsentiert sich
dann ganz anders
und hat eine andere Ausstrahlung.
Aber der schmerzhafteste Teil
einer solchen Show
sind definitiv die Schuhe.
Ohne Ernährungsplan
und krasse Diäten
läuft im professionellen
Bodybuilding gar nichts.
Man fragt sich etwas, wie viel
Kontrolle über den Körper gesund ist
und wo die Sucht beginnt.
Wir lernen jetzt zwei junge Frauen
kennen, Flavia und Naera,
die beide
mit dieser Kontrolle am Kämpfen sind.
Sie kämpfen gegen ihre Magersucht
und fürs Überleben.
"Hallo, Magersucht. Du hast meine
letzten Jahre komplett zerstört."
"Du hast meinen Körper
fast verhungern lassen."
"Wegen dir musste ich dreimal
mit einer Sonde ernährt werden."
"Während dieser Zeit musste ich
höllische Schmerzen aushalten."
"Einmal wäre ich wegen dir
fast draufgegangen."
"Wegen dir hätte ich fast
meinen besten Freund verloren."
"Viele Freundschaften
hast du zerstört."
"Du hast meine Familie überfordert.
Ich hasse dich so sehr."
"Keine Freude, keinen Lebenswillen,
keine Kraft mehr. Und vieles mehr."
"Du hast mir so viel genommen.
Für dich war ich nie dünn genug,
nie krank, nie diszipliniert genug."
"Du wolltest mich umbringen,
und ich habe mitgemacht,
weil ich dachte,
dass ich es verdiene."
"Doch tue ich das wirklich?
Who knows?"
Naera Giaimo ist 24 Jahre alt.
Mit knapp 16
trat die Magersucht in ihr Leben.
Es kam schleichend.
Zuerst, das weiss ich noch,
mochte ich nicht so essen.
Dann habe ich irgendwie ...
Dann haben wir erfahren, dass
jemand in der Familie krank ist.
Ich habe gemerkt:
Wenn ich nicht esse,
kommen diese Gefühle nicht hoch.
So hat sich das
eigentlich manifestiert.
Und weil ich
immer weniger Gefühle hatte,
war ich motiviert,
noch weniger zu essen.
Das Zentrum für Essstörungen
des Universitätsspitals Zürich -
seit fünf Wochen
Flavia Maiers Zuhause.
Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.
In einer stationären Therapie
muss Flavia Maier lernen,
wieder zu essen.
Sie haben fast 4 kg zugenommen.
Das ist ein Erfolg.
Aber ich denke,
so einfach ist das nicht für Sie.
Auf die letzten zwei, drei Messungen
habe ich mich wirklich gefreut.
Ich konnte sagen:
"Das ist der richtige Weg.
Das willst du."
Es wird nicht besser,
wenn das Gewicht wieder runtergeht.
Es wird nicht besser.
Ich habe das erfahren.
Das muss ich mir wirklich einreden.
Flavia Maier erkrankte mit 15.
Sie wollte beliebter,
interessanter, einfach anders werden.
Die Magersucht
versprach dem Teenager
einfache Lösungen
für komplexe Probleme.
Ich glaube, ich bekam durch
das Nicht-Essen, durch das Abnehmen
von dieser Anorexie, dieser kranken
Stimme in mir, eine Bestätigung ...
... die mir von der Aussenwelt
nicht gegeben wurde,
oder die ich nicht gehört habe.
Ich konnte mir auch selber
keine Bestätigung für etwas geben,
das ich vielleicht
gut gemacht hatte.
Ich war mir gegenüber
immer sehr kritisch.
Wenn der Kritiker nur auftaucht,
wenn du zunimmst oder isst,
und du das eigentlich
umgehen kannst, indem du nicht isst,
ist das ziemlich verlockend.
Im Zentrum für Essstörungen
lernt Flavia Maier
zusammen mit elf Mitpatientinnen
zu unterscheiden,
wann die Magersucht zu ihr spricht,
und wann ihr eigenes Ich.
Welche verwirrende Dialoge
so entstehen,
können Gesunde kaum nachvollziehen.
Es ist sehr darauf fokussiert,
dass es zu viel war,
dass mein Körper
das nicht braucht ...
... dass ich bei der nächsten
Mahlzeit weniger essen muss usw.
Es geht nicht per se um das Gewicht.
Ich denke nicht,
dass ich zunehme, wenn ich so esse.
Eher, dass ich meinem Körper
die Nahrung, die er braucht,
vorenthalten will.
Diese Nahrung
haben Sie nicht verdient?
Nein.
- Warum?
Er hat ja nichts geleistet.
Leistung, Perfektionismus, Kontrolle.
Sie bilden,
neben genetischen Faktoren,
oft den Nährboden, auf dem
die Magersucht gedeihen kann.
Ich wollte immer
alles perfekt machen.
Egal wo - im Schulsport,
in der Freizeit ...
Ich hatte immer die Stimme
der Magersucht im Kopf.
Wenn ich mal nicht gegessen hatte,
sagte mir die Magersucht:
"Gut gemacht! Mach weiter so!"
Und diesen Satz, "Gut gemacht!",
manchmal auch "Perfekt gemacht!",
wenn ich gar nichts gegessen hatte,
wollte ich immer wieder hören.
Dass ich etwas leisten konnte.
Selfies, sog. Bodychecks:
die Trophäen der Magersüchtigen.
Die bildhafte Frage
an die Krankheit:
"Bin ich dünn und krank genug?"
Die Antwort: ein immerwährendes Nein.
In der schlimmsten Zeit
mochte ich nicht mehr aufstehen.
Mir wurde dauernd schwarz vor Augen.
Mir war kalt.
24 Std., sieben Tage die Woche,
egal, wie viel ich anhatte.
Ich dachte oft, dass ich lieber
nicht mehr auf dieser Welt wäre.
Ich konnte einfach nicht mehr.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob ich es je herausschaffen würde.
Unzählige erfolglose Therapien
liegen auch hinter Flavia Maier.
Je länger die Krankheit dauert, desto
kleiner wird die Chance auf Heilung.
Gruppengesprächstherapie
im Zentrum für Essstörungen.
Thema heute: Schuldgefühle.
Ich verspüre meiner Mutter, meinem
Vater und meiner Schwester gegenüber
viel, viel Schuld, weil ...
Ich habe so viele Dinge gemacht ...
Kaum hatte ich sie gemacht,
merkte ich: "Oh mein Gott,
das ist das Schlimmste,
was ich hätte machen können."
Ich ging weinend zu meiner Familie
und bat um Entschuldigung.
Aber in dem Moment,
in dem man es macht,
ist die Schuld wie weggeblasen.
Die überrollt einen
im Nachhinein extrem.
Was für Dinge waren das?
Sie müssen keine Details nennen.
Ich log sie an, ich liess
vor ihnen Essen verschwinden,
ich bewegte mich,
obwohl sie Nein gesagt hatten,
ich stritt mich mit ihnen
über Portionengrössen.
Ja. Ich habe alles gemacht, was ich
eigentlich nicht machen würde.
Vor acht Jahren hielt im Haus
von Markus und Gitte Maier
ein neues Familienmitglied Einzug:
Flavias Magersucht.
Diese säte Zwietracht rund ums Essen,
wo immer es ging.
Beinahe wäre die Ehe der Maiers
daran zerbrochen.
Um die ganze Familie,
auch Flavias ältere,
gesunde Schwester zu schützen,
entschieden Markus und Gitte Maier
letztes Jahr,
Flavia nicht mehr
zu sich nach Hause zu nehmen,
wenn Therapien
ohne Erfolg abgebrochen würden.
Wir haben es ...
wie viele Male probiert, Gitte?
Ein paarmal.
Wir haben es ein paarmal probiert.
Das Problem ist,
dass es gehen würde,
wenn sie das,
was wir ihr an Essen vorsetzen ...
Wenn sie sagen würde:
"Okay, das nehme ich."
In der Klinik
hat sie zwei Stück Brot.
Bei uns nimmt sie ein Stück Brot.
In der Klinik hat sie Butter,
bei uns nimmt sie Margarine.
Das führt einfach dazu,
dass es immer Streit geben wird.
Und das geht nicht.
Die Emotionen explodieren.
Und dann
schreien wir uns gegenseitig an.
Das ist kein fruchtbarer Boden.
Und wir haben auch keine Kraft mehr.
Wir können nicht mehr.
Mit Magersucht sind auch
viele Fachleute überfordert.
Betroffene - zu 90 % Frauen -
fallen nicht selten durch die Maschen
unseres Gesundheitswesens.
Ihr Body-Mass-Index ist für
psychiatrische Einrichtungen zu tief,
für Akutspitäler
sind die Patientinnen zu wenig krank.
Dabei hat Magersucht mit 5-10 %
eine der höchsten Sterblichkeitsraten
aller psychischen Krankheiten.
Betroffene sterben
an Herz- oder Multiorganversagen
oder an Infektionen.
Flavia Maier mit 14 Jahren.
Die folgenden, verstörenden Bilder
ihres ausgehungerten Körpers
entstanden vor gut einem Jahr.
Flavia wog noch 24 kg.
Ich war total hoffnungslos.
Ich dachte, ich sei so viele Male
aufgestanden und wieder hingefallen,
dass es nicht klappen wird.
Ich werde es nicht schaffen.
Ich war fest davon überzeugt,
dass das nie aufhören würde.
Dass ich nie wieder
normal werden könne.
Ich fand, es wäre besser zu sterben,
als so weiterzuleben.
Flavia war in einem Programm,
in einem sehr schlechten Zustand.
Die Ärzte
machten sich wirklich Sorgen.
Sie sagten, wir müssten reagieren,
sonst würde unsere Tochter sterben.
Sie liessen uns
zu einem Gespräch kommen
und stellten uns
vor die Entscheidung -
weil wir eine Patientenverfügung
für unsere Tochter haben -,
ob wir im Boot seien,
sie nochmals parenteral zu ernähren
und so ihr Leben zu retten.
Wenn wir nicht im Boot seien,
würden sie sie
auf die Palliativstation verlegen,
damit sie sterben dürfe.
- Mit 22.
Mit 22.
Wir gingen nach Hause
und schliefen eine Nacht darüber.
Wir setzten uns wirklich
mit diesem Gedanken auseinander.
Wir überlegten uns wirklich,
ob wir das nochmals wollen.
Wir entschieden uns: "Flavia,
du bleibst hier auf dieser Welt."
Im Zentrum von Naera Giaimos Wohnung
in Sargans: ein verhüllter Spiegel.
Er ist die meiste Zeit zugedeckt,
zu meinem eigenen Schutz.
Wenn ich keinen guten Tag habe
und direkt in den Spiegel sehe,
macht mich das
manchmal noch traurig oder wütend.
Wenn er zugedeckt ist,
kann ich selber entscheiden,
ob ich mich anschaue,
ob ich mich bewusst anschaue.
Dann stelle ich mich dem.
Von aussen sieht man Naera Giaimo
ihre Krankheit nicht mehr an.
Umso überraschender:
Die Magersucht gibt ihr im Alltag
noch immer den Takt vor.
Es ist abends um 18 Uhr.
Was haben Sie heute
schon alles gegessen?
Heute noch gar nichts.
- Noch gar nichts?
Es ist für mich auch einfacher,
am Abend zu essen.
Weshalb ist es einfacher?
- Weil ich danach schlafen kann.
Wenn das starke Gefühle auslöst
oder wenn ich mich dann
nicht wohlfühle,
weiss ich, dass ich im schlimmsten
Fall schlafen gehen kann.
Und wenn es keine Gefühle auslöst,
umso besser.
Aber ich hätte dann
diese Notlösung, sozusagen.
Einmal pro Woche
trifft sich Flavia Maier,
die von einer IV-Rente lebt,
mit ihren Eltern.
Es ist kalt. Die Restaurants
sind wegen der Pandemie geschlossen.
Man trifft sich in der Wohnung
von Flavias Schwester.
Die Stimmung ist gedrückt.
Flavias Gewichtszunahme
stagniert seit Wochen.
700 g pro Woche müssten es sein,
sonst droht der Abbruch der Therapie.
Das Haus der Eltern
steht ihr nicht mehr offen.
Zu heftig sind die Streitereien
des Essens wegen.
Ich weiss,
dass sie sich Sorgen machen,
dass es ihnen Mühe macht.
Aber bei mir kommt das an als: "Wir
können nicht mehr für dich da sein."
Das tut enorm weh.
Gleichzeitig weiss ich, dass es
nicht persönlich gemeint ist.
Sie haben Verständnis dafür,
dass Sie nicht mehr nach Hause
können, dort wohnen, leben?
Wenn ich nicht genügend
gegen die Krankheit kämpfen kann,
verstehe ich es.
Ich glaube,
zuschauen müssen ist am schlimmsten.
Zehn Tage später, frühmorgens im
Zentrum für Essstörungen in Zürich.
Der schicksalshafte Gang zur Waage.
Flavia Maier schaffte es nicht,
weiter an Gewicht zuzulegen.
Die Magersucht hatte einmal mehr
die stärkeren Argumente.
Bei der Geschichte
dieser zwei jungen Frauen
geht es Ihnen sicher gleich wie mir:
Man ist total betroffen.
Ich wollte mich hier
mit den beiden treffen,
aber Flavia
musste leider kurzfristig absagen.
Es geht ihr nicht so gut,
wie man gehofft hat.
Sie ist im Moment
in einer Klinik in München
und lässt ausrichten,
dass sie weiterkämpft.
Wie es Naera geht,
finde ich gleich raus.
Hallo!
- Hallo, Naera.
Hallo, Mona.
- Freut mich, dich kennenzulernen.
Cool. Das weiss ich.
Du hast eine neue Wohnung.
Das ist die neue Wohnung.
Über diese Veränderung
wurde ich informiert.
Ah! Aber ...
Ihn oder sie kenne ich
noch nicht aus dem TV.
Nein. Den habe ich seit Oktober.
Das ist Kiki.
Darf ich mal schauen?
- Du kannst gerne näher ran.
Er ist ein bisschen schüchtern,
wenn jemand zu Besuch ist.
Das ist Kiki.
Ihn habe ich, seit er ein Baby war.
Er konnte noch nicht fliegen.
Er ist nur am Boden herumgelaufen.
Ich habe ihn seit Oktober.
Ich versuche,
ihm sprechen beizubringen.
Das kann er mittlerweile auch.
- Ja?
Aber nicht auf Kommando.
Das ist schade.
Wir können ihn gerne rausnehmen.
Komm! Er ist etwas scheu.
Ja, du bist etwas scheu.
* Lautes Zwitschern *
Zuerst musste ich lernen,
Verantwortung
für mich selber zu übernehmen.
Als ich hierher zog, dachte ich,
nun könne ich auch die Verantwortung
für jemand anderen übernehmen.
Ich wollte ein Haustier.
Zuerst wollte ich einen Hamster.
Aber die sind nachtaktiv,
das ist unglücklich.
Deshalb entschied ich mich
für einen Wellensittich.
Bist das du?
- Ja.
Das auch.
Dort zeige ich den Mittelfinger.
Hier hast du keine Bilder
aus den Zeiten,
in denen du ganz, ganz dünn warst.
Nein.
Das habe ich bewusst so gemacht.
Ich mache immer Kreativbücher.
Dort setze ich mich
bewusst damit auseinander
und klebe die Fotos dort ein.
Aber ich möchte die
nicht jeden Tag anschauen.
Wenn du ein Bild von dir
aus dieser Zeit anschaust:
Was denkst du über diese Naera?
Ich bin froh,
dass sie durchgehalten hat.
Diese Krankheit, das Hungern,
hat dir
deine ganze Teenagerphase genommen.
Ja. Man sagt, das seien
die schönsten
und aufregendsten Jahre im Leben.
Manchmal bin ich auch
wütend auf mich selber.
Sicher? Macht dich das wütend?
- Ja.
Andere gingen in dieser Zeit reisen,
machten ein Studium ...
Und ich war mehr oder weniger
in der Klinik.
Ich sehe gerade,
dass der Spiegel nebendran steht.
Genau.
Im Film war der immer verhüllt.
Ja, den hatte ich immer zugedeckt.
Ich habe mich entschieden,
ihn in dieser Wohnung
nicht mehr zuzudecken.
Was hast du gedacht, wenn du früher
in den Spiegel geschaut hast?
Meistens dass ich fett sei,
dass ich nicht gut genug sei.
Dass ich ... ja ...
nicht hierhergehöre.
Bis vor ein paar Monaten
sah ich für mich keinen Nutzen.
"Dich braucht es nicht."
So hast du das erlebt.
Genau. Aber das hat sich in den
letzten Monaten auch verändert.
U.a. auch wegen Kiki.
Er braucht mich,
damit er leben kann.
Und auch weil ich das Gefühl habe,
dass ich meine Aufgaben
für die Zukunft gefunden habe.
Die habe ich schon lange gesucht.
Ja. Und was sind die?
Meine Geschichte so nutzen,
dass ich anderen helfen kann ...
... und Mut machen kann,
dass es sich lohnt, zu kämpfen,
dass es sich lohnt, dranzubleiben.
Ja. Einfach so.
Einen richtig entspannten Umgang
haben leider, wenn wir ehrlich sind,
nur wenige von uns.
Vis-à-vis von mir
sitzt Yves Bossart,
Moderator von "Sternstunde
Philosophie" und Philosoph.
Hast du einen entspannten Umgang
mit deinem Körper? Eine fiese Frage.
Ich glaube,
es ist sehr philosophisch,
dass wir ein sonderbares Verhältnis
zu unserem Körper haben.
Wir haben einen Körper.
Nur schon, wie wir das sagen:
"Ich habe einen Körper."
Als ob es ein Hund
oder eine Tasche wäre.
Wir sind auch unser Körper.
Diese Ambivalenz:
Auf eine Art
sind wir geistige Wesen,
eingespannt
zwischen dem Göttlich-Geistigen
und dem Tierisch-Körperlichen -
so wurde das seit Plato beschrieben.
Und dann mit dem Christentum
und den Religionen ...
Erklärt das,
weshalb man in der heutigen Zeit
so hohe Ansprüche hat,
oder weshalb es so viele Leute gibt,
die an ihrem Körper herumschrauben
oder denken, dass sie so,
wie sie sind, nicht richtig sind?
Nein, dort kommt
eine neue Dimension dazu.
Ein Aspekt ist, dass wir
den Körper nicht mehr brauchen.
Viele Menschen brauchen den Körper
nicht mehr zum Arbeiten.
Wir sitzen am Computer
und benutzen die Hände und den Kopf.
Weil wir ihn nicht mehr brauchen,
ist er paradoxerweise so
wichtig geworden, als Statussymbol.
Was ich als Zweites
noch sagen würde:
Körper
hat viel mit Kontrolle zu tun.
Man kann genau kontrollieren,
was man isst.
Man kann den Muskelaufbau
kontrollieren
und spüren, was passiert, wenn man
drei, vier Wiederholungen macht.
Man kann daran herumfeilen,
wie an einem Kunstwerk.
Und das in einer Welt,
in der wir uns ohnmächtig fühlen
und über vieles
keine Kontrolle mehr haben.
Weil sie so komplex ist.
- So komplex, vernetzt, dynamisch.
Es ist eine Ersatzhandlung
in einer Welt, in der wir
die Kontrolle verloren haben.
Ist das schlecht?
Das ist nicht per se schlecht,
aber es kommt zu Auswüchsen.
Das steht in Zusammenhang
mit der Selbstoptimierung,
mit Medien, mit Werbung,
mit den sozialen Medien,
mit den Körperbildern,
die uns dort präsentiert werden.
Das alles
baut einen Druck auf uns auf,
sodass wir in den Spiegel schauen
und finden, etwas sei nicht gut.
Diese Bilder, die wir zu Tausenden
aufsaugen, beeinflussen uns.
Wir verinnerlichen sie als Norm,
als Normalität,
als das, was sein sollte.
Ich schaue mich an und sehe
Fettpolster, zu wenig Muskeln usw.
So fängt es an,
und dann wird es gefährlich.
Etwas, was diese aufgehübschten
Körper auf Social Media geben -
und darum geht es -,
ist Aufmerksamkeit.
Aufmerksamkeit, Applaus,
in Form von Daumen hoch,
in Form von Herzchen,
in Form von Likes. Darum geht es.
Was sind junge Menschen bereit,
für diese Aufmerksamkeit zu machen?
Das schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Eigentlich kann man Bilder machen,
aber das geht gerade nicht.
Es geht nicht.
Ich mache immer so.
Und dann gerade.
Ich habe nur ein Doppelkinn,
wenn ich so mache:
Aber wenn ich normal
nach vorne schaue, geht das gut.
Ich finde,
ein Bild muss perfekt sein.
Z.B. hier.
Oder hier habe ich auch eine Beule.
Und hier habe ich einen Kratzer.
Und das kann ich mit einer App
namens Facetune alles wegmachen.
Weshalb lässt man das nicht einfach?
Weil auf Instagram
die Welt perfekt ist
und jeder perfekt aussieht.
Das perfekte Selfie.
Ein bisschen glätten ...
Was glättest du denn da?
- Diesen Ausschlag.
Du glättest die Pickel weg.
- Ja, sozusagen.
Meine Augen
mache ich auch noch grüner.
Das ist Beschiss, nicht?
Ich weiss.
Aber Instagram ist ein Beschiss.
* Unverständliches Reden *
Sein Online-Ich hat nur wenig
mit seinem Alltag
als Migros-Lehrling gemein.
Im Kosmos der sozialen Medien
ist Younes Model und Entertainer.
Zehntausende
vorwiegend weibliche Fans
folgen ihm auf Plattformen
wie Instagram, Snapchat oder TikTok.
Es kann sein, dass ich
bis zu 1 Std. brauche.
Es kommt drauf an.
Manchmal brauche ich länger,
weil ich mehr Lidschatten auftrage.
Ich schminke mich stärker,
damit es auf den Bildern
besser aussieht. Ja.
Das hat auch mit Instagram zu tun.
Man sieht halt, wie sich alle
so schön schminken und probiert es.
Sie sieht einfach megagut aus.
Von hier
hast du auch die Augenbrauen?
Ja, ungefähr.
Die sehen ähnlich aus.
* Piepsen *
Was kommen da für Benachrichtigungen?
- Fans, auf Snapchat.
"Oh mein Gott, Younes, ich liebe
dich, bleib so, wie du bist!"
Ich schreibe jeweils zurück.
"Merci vielmals."
Du bekommst viele Herzchen.
- Immer Herzchen.
Ich kann nicht ohne Social Media.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist wie jemand, der raucht.
Man kann nicht aufhören.
Eine Sucht?
- Eine Sucht. Genau.
Wonach bist du süchtig?
Danach, mich
in der Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen.
Danach, mein Leben
zu veröffentlichen,
damit andere sehen,
was ich privat
und sonst noch mache,
weil sie das interessiert.
Ja.
Aber was gibt das dir?
- Mir?
Ja.
- Ein gutes Gefühl.
Weshalb?
Weil Leute an mir
interessiert sind. Genau.
Das ist Kylie Jenner.
Ich fände es schon schön, wenn ich
wie Kylie Jenner aussehen würde,
aber das
sind halt einfach Vorbilder.
Selfie-Queen Kylie Jenner
hat es vom TV-Sternchen
zur Multimillionärin geschafft.
Dank zielstrebiger Vermarktung
ihres Lebens.
Und ihrer eigenen Beautyprodukte
in den sozialen Medien.
Gerade Kylie Jenner ist nicht nur
so schön, weil sie sich schminkt.
Sie hat ja auch nachgeholfen.
Ja, sie hat nachgeholfen.
Das stört mich nicht. Ich habe
selber auch schon nachgeholfen.
Wo genau?
- Die Lippen und meine Nase.
Ich finde, wenn man sich so
wohler fühlt, soll man es machen.
Wow, wow, halt an!
Seine beste Freundin hat sich längst
an Younes' Selfie-Manie gewöhnt.
LOL.
Das ist voll ...
- Okay, so.
Es ist verdammt heiss.
- Ja.
Weshalb braucht er deiner Meinung
nach so viel Anerkennung?
Du bist sehr frech.
- Ja, also ...
Vielleicht bekam er
nicht immer 100 % Aufmerksamkeit.
Er wurde auch gemobbt.
Genau.
Ich glaube, ihm zeigt das,
dass er den Leuten gefällt,
dass er jemand ist,
dass er cool ist,
dass man über ihn redet.
Und das gibt ihm einfach Sicherheit.
Ja.
- Hat sie recht?
Ja, sie hat recht.
Zelebrieren des eigenen Ichs.
Wie Younes sucht auch Michelle
in den sozialen Medien
nach Selbstbestätigung.
Wer Likes und Followers jagt, muss
aus der Bilderflut herausstechen.
Bewährtes Mittel: aufreizende Posen.
Und so sieht dich
die ganze Welt im Bikini.
Im Schwimmbad
sieht mich auch jeder im Bikini.
Ob auf Instagram oder im Schwimmbad
macht keinen Unterschied.
Die Leute können ins Schwimmbad
kommen und sehen mich im Bikini.
Ich posiere nicht so:
"Ah, mein Arsch! Ah, meine Möpse!"
Und dies und das.
Ich posiere einfach so.
Ich finde auch,
dass es gut aussieht.
Nicht wegen "sex sells".
- Das hat nichts damit zu tun?
Das ist weiblich.
Ich finde, das ist weiblich.
Manche nennen mich Drecksschlampe,
Drecksfotze, solche Sachen.
Dann frage ich mich jeweils:
"Was habe ich dir getan?"
"Ich stelle Fotos ins Internet,
same as you."
"Und du
gibst solche Dinge von dir."
Ich habe mir das tätowieren lassen.
"You know my name, not my story."
So viele Menschen urteilen,
ohne zu wissen, wer du bist.
Aber du könntest dich
einfach ganz verabschieden.
Ich möchte nicht aufhören.
Das wäre ja langweilig.
Ich brauche mein Handy.
Und dann brauche ich etwas
auf dem Handy,
damit ich etwas damit machen kann.
Deshalb würde ich es nicht löschen.
Ich brauche das. Für meine Seele.
* Klicken *
Auch Chiara präsentiert sich
auf ihrem Instagram-Account
öffentlich im Bikini.
Worauf schaust du jetzt?
Zum einen,
ob ich einen flachen Bauch habe.
Eigentlich bin ich dafür,
dass man nicht immer
einen flachen Bauch haben muss.
Dass man nicht denkt -
weil das
die Fitnessmodels so vermitteln -,
dass nur
ein flacher Bauch schön ist.
Aber du schaust trotzdem drauf?
- Ich achte mich trotzdem drauf.
Das ist völlig ...
Es macht gar keinen Sinn.
Aber es kommt gut an bei den Leuten.
Du fotografierst dich
auch häufig von der Seite.
Eigentlich fast nur von der Seite.
Ich glaube,
ich habe keine Fotos von vorne.
Weshalb nur seitlich?
- Ich fühle mich so wohler.
Und ich denke, ich sehe von
der Seite besser als von vorne aus.
Dafür sieht man den Hintern besser.
- Ja, das ist schon so.
Man bekommt mehr Likes, wenn man
es macht. Das ist heutzutage so.
Der Rest ist noch ...
Herzen fliegen Younes
nicht nur in Form von Likes zu.
Selbst seine Mutter ist überrascht,
wie viele Fans
für ihren Sohn schwärmen.
Herzchen und alle verliebt ...
Sie schreiben dir Bücher.
Younes, der ohne Vater aufwuchs,
lebt heute gemeinsam mit
seiner Mutter, ihrem neuen Mann
und seinem kleinen Halbbruder
zusammen.
Was fehlt ihm, das er hier fühlt,
mit diesen Likes?
Eine gewisse Liebe, denke ich.
- Die fehlt ihm?
Ja.
- Wessen Liebe?
Sehr wahrscheinlich
auch die seines Vaters.
Und Sie haben ...
- Ich habe alles probiert.
Vielleicht habe ich ihm
zu viel gegeben.
Ich habe alles, alles ...
An Liebe? An Anerkennung auch?
- Liebe, Anerkennung ...
Ich habe Liebe
eher durch Dinge erfahren.
Geld, Materielles.
Ich habe Geld bekommen.
Ich habe alles bekommen,
was ich wollte. Und ...
Von wem?
- Von meiner Mutter.
Von deiner Mutter, ja.
Und du hättest gerne
etwas anders gehabt?
Ich denke schon.
- Vielleicht, ich weiss es nicht.
Ich war immer glücklich
mit den Dingen, die ich bekam.
Ich war auch zu jung.
Ich arbeitete viel.
13 Std.
Ich war immer am Arbeiten.
Ich sah ihn, wenn er aufstand
und wenn er ins Bett ging.
Dazwischen arbeitete ich.
Da ich allein war ...
... beim Aufziehen und Erziehen.
Da habe ich ihm ...
Ich hatte mehr Stress als ...
Mir Zeit für ihn nehmen.
So, wie ich mir jetzt Zeit
für Cristian nehme.
Seit fünf Jahren
ist Chiara auf Instagram aktiv,
zeigt öffentlich
die Veränderung ihres Körpers,
von der nur 25 kg leichten
Magersüchtigen
zur durchtrainierten Sportlerin.
Mit den Vorher-Nachher-Bildern
will Chiara zeigen,
dass es einen Weg
aus der Krankheit gibt.
Doch die Plattform hilft auch ihr.
Über 53'000 Instagram-Nutzer
folgen ihr,
schicken virtuelle Herzchen
und Zuspruch.
Pro Bild bekommt die Studentin
zwischen 1'500 und 4'000 Likes.
Eigentlich
ist es nur eine Scheinwelt.
Aber es freut halt trotzdem.
Ja.
Hast du eine Erklärung,
warum das bei dir so ist?
Ich selber habe
schon wenig Selbstvertrauen.
Ich bin normalerweise
ein sehr zurückhaltender Mensch,
auf Instagram aber nicht.
Ich habe mich überwunden,
es zu machen,
weil ich damit anderen helfe.
Aber ich bin schon selbstkritisch
und habe wenig Wertschätzung
für mich selber.
Deshalb denke ich,
dass es mir guttut,
wenn ich
positive Kommentare bekomme.
Nach dem Vorbild
ihrer Instagram-Idole
will Michelle ihre Lippen
erneut aufspritzen lassen.
Der Eingriff ist mit der Unterschrift
der Eltern ab 16 Jahren erlaubt.
Die 350 Fr. teure Lippenvergrösserung
ist für Michelle gratis.
Als Gegenleistung macht die Schülerin
auf ihren Social-Media-Accounts
für die Beautyklinik Werbung.
Kannst du vielleicht schauen,
dass man das schön sieht?
Darf ich es zeigen?
Hier sieht man es.
Sie hat total perfekte Lippen.
Ihr Herz
ist viel weiter auseinander,
deshalb kann man das
so schön betonen.
Das hast du nicht.
Schau mal! Hier ist ein Spiegel.
Du musst nicht ins Handy schauen.
* Klicken *
Mach mal deinen Mund etwas auf!
Und schön so bleiben.
Tief Luft holen.
Und es geht los.
Schön auflassen, bitte.
* Klicken *
Und, wie gefällt es dir?
- Perfekt.
Ein durchtrainiertes Hinterteil liegt
dank Instagram und Co. im Trend.
Auch bei Chiara.
Der Lohn für das Hardcore-Training:
Extra-Likes für die Kehrseite.
Das Phänomen der selbst foto-
grafierten Hintern hat einen Namen:
Belfie - eine Kombination
aus dem Wort Butt, zu Deutsch Po,
und Selfie.
Das ist die Belfie-Queen.
Man sagt, sie habe es erfunden.
Was hat sie erfunden?
- Sie hätte mit Belfies angefangen.
Den Hintern in Szene setzen?
Das wird heutzutage
so richtig gehypt.
Es geht weniger um die Oberweite,
wie es früher der Fall war.
Heute ist es das Hinterteil.
That's not real.
Das sind verdammt viele.
Younes nächste
Selbstvermarktungsaktion:
ein Fantreffen.
Ihr Idol steht real vor ihnen.
Für die Kids ist das die grosse
Chance auf ein gemeinsames Selfie
oder sogar ein Playback-Video
für die eigene Onlinegalerie.
Danke!
-Bitte.
Massenhaft Anerkennung und Zuneigung.
Younes bekommt
von seinen Fans heute das,
was er in seiner Kindheit vermisste.
Du bist ja jetzt 18.
Hast du schon mal überlegt,
wie es wäre, wenn du keinen Fame
und keine Fans mehr hättest?
Das habe ich mich schon gefragt,
aber gross Gedanken
habe ich mir nicht darüber gemacht.
Ich lasse es auf mich zukommen.
Aber was wird,
wenn du keine Likes mehr bekommst?
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Das wäre Scheisse.
Körperkult und Optimierung
liegen im Trend.
Dabei ist der Körper weit mehr
als nur äussere Erscheinung.
Was, wenn er nicht mehr funktioniert?
Was, wenn er v.a. eines ist:
Schmerz?
Besuch bei Tetraplegikerin
Franziska Quadri.
Seit einem Gleitschirmunfall
ist die 46-Jährige
vom Hals abwärts gelähmt.
Hallo!
- Hallo!
Ich bin hier hinten.
- Die Tür geht von allein auf.
Ja. Einfach reinkommen.
Darf ich einfach so
ins Schlafzimmer kommen?
Freut mich sehr. Franziska.
- Hallo Mona.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ich bin Mona.
Das ist mein Vater.
- Das freut mich sehr.
Wie hast du die Tür geöffnet?
Mit dem Handy. Ich habe
ein spezielles Programm darauf.
Damit habe ich
zuerst die Eingangstür
und dann die Wohnungstür geöffnet.
Alles mit diesem Schlauch hier.
Ich kann so einen Impuls geben,
und dann geht das auf.
Hörst du?
Jetzt geht sie automatisch auf.
Okay. Siehst du, wer draussen ist?
Nein.
Ich muss auf gut Glück aufmachen.
Dann machst du irgendjemandem auf,
und dann steht der Paketpöstler
im Schlafzimmer?
Meistens weiss ich ja,
dass die Spitex kommt oder so.
Dann öffne ich.
Wenn ich nicht weiss, wer es ist,
öffne ich manchmal auch nicht.
In unserem Fall wusstest du,
dass wir kommen.
Du hast auch gesagt, dass du noch
im Bett bist, habe einen Grund:
damit ich sehe,
wie aufwendig es für dich ist,
alltägliche Dinge wie nur schon
aufzustehen zu bewältigen.
Ja.
Ich stehe meistens gegen Mittag auf.
Das ist die Zeit,
zu der ich aufstehe.
Ich mag nicht den ganzen Tag
im Rollstuhl sein.
Jetzt muss mein Vater
mich in den Rollstuhl setzen
und mich zurechtrücken.
Das dauert einen Moment.
Wer macht das,
wenn dein Papa nicht hier ist?
Die Spitex
und eine Assistenz helfen mir.
Auch meine Eltern helfen mir viel.
Ich nehme die Decke weg.
Das Kopfkissen weg.
Was spürst du jetzt?
Das ist Spastik.
Wenn man mich berührt,
bekomme ich spastische Krämpfe.
Die entstehen durch die Lähmung.
Schmerzt das?
- Ja, das schmerzt sehr.
Ich habe auch
neuropathische Schmerzen.
Wenn man mich berührt,
schmerzt das auch sehr.
Zusammen mit der Spastik
ist das unangenehm.
Es ist ein Kampf,
mich aus dem Bett zu bringen.
Zuerst etwas nach hinten schieben.
Jetzt haben wir es gleich.
Kannst du mir die Hüfte noch
ein bisschen zum Fenster drehen?
Wie ist das für dich, dass ihr
jede Berührung von dir wehtut?
Obwohl es etwas Schönes sein sollte,
sein Kind zu berühren.
Ja. Das war am Anfang schwer.
Man erschrak beinahe.
Man nahm sich zurück.
Heute weiss ich: Wenn ich einfach
weitermache, ist es erledigt.
Für sie ist es sicher schmerzhaft,
aber dann sitzt sie.
Wenn ich
noch drei-, viermal loslasse
und sie wieder nehmen muss,
ist das für sie schwieriger.
Dann muss sie
einmal mehr auf die Zähne beissen.
Mhm. Gut.
Franziska Quadri vor sechs Jahren.
Ihren Unfall hat die ehemalige
Werberin in Bildern verarbeitet.
Hebt man ihren linken Arm an,
kann sie diesen schwach bewegen.
Es geschah 2009.
Beim Starten riss eine Windböe
Franziskas Gleitschirm
ein paar Meter in die Höhe.
Darauf stolperte sie
und stürzte kopfüber in eine Wiese.
Beim Aufprall
brach ihre Halswirbelsäule.
Ich glaube, ganz am Anfang
habe ich nur geweint.
Ich war einfach nur todtraurig.
Irgendwann
verwandelt es sich in Wut.
Eine Wut gegen sich,
eine Wut gegen die anderen.
Irgendwann wird es zu Eifersucht.
Andere können es noch,
du kannst es nicht mehr.
Man geht
durch verschiedene Gefühlsebenen.
Und heute ist es so ...
Ich glaube,
ich ärgere mich nicht mehr darüber.
Ich muss das
einfach hinter mir lassen
und es so annehmen, wie es ist.
Sonst mache ich mir keinen Gefallen.
Besonders schlimm sind ihre Schmerzen
im kalten und feuchten Winter.
Aber Franziska hat einen Plan.
In der Hoffnung auf Linderung
fliegt sie für zwei Monate
in die Wärme der Kanaren.
Teneriffa.
Franziska hat im Süden der Insel
eine rollstuhlgängige Finca gemietet.
Ihre Eltern und ihre persönliche
Assistentin begleiten sie.
Auch ihre Schwester Andrea
ist für zwei Wochen angereist.
Hat man kein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn man selber noch geniessen kann,
und die eigene Schwester nicht?
- Ja, das war ein grosses Thema,
v.a. am Anfang. Sich selber das
wieder zu erlauben, zu geniessen.
Es dauerte recht lange,
bis ich das wieder konnte.
Aber ich habe es gelernt.
Und ich mache Franzi die grösste
Freude, wenn ich es mache.
Mit Therapien kann Franziska
wohl ihre Muskeln stärken.
Ihre Arme und Beine wird sie dennoch
nie mehr wirklich bewegen können.
In den letzten Jahren
kehrte immer mehr Gefühl
in die gelähmten Gliedmassen zurück.
Dadurch wurden aber ihre
neuropathischen Schmerzen heftiger.
Franziska sagte mir,
in der ersten Zeit nach dem Unfall
hätte sie sich gefragt,
ob es nicht besser gewesen wäre,
wenn man sie nicht gerettet hätte.
Sind Ihnen solche Gedanken
auch schon durch den Kopf gegangen?
Nicht direkt nach dem Unfall.
Da war man einfach froh,
dass sie noch hier war.
Aber wenn man dann immer
zuschauen muss, wie sie leidet ...
... dann frage ich mich, ob es für
sie nicht einfacher gewesen wäre.
Aber ...
Aber sie ist hochintelligent.
Und dass sie im Kopf
noch voll hier ist,
ist für uns wahnsinnig schön.
Aber wenn sie
nicht mehr voll da wäre,
wäre es für sie
vielleicht einfacher.
Aber wir sind einfach glücklich,
dass wir sie noch haben.
Und wir versuchen, ihr zu helfen,
ihrem Leben einen Sinn zu geben.
It's coming now.
Ins Wasser gehe ich extrem gerne.
Der Körper fühlt sich im Wasser
weniger schwer und gelähmt an.
Das macht mir grossen Spass.
Versöhnt Sie das
auch ein bisschen mit Ihrem Körper?
Ja ... Zu meinem Körper habe ich
schon eher ein gestörtes Verhältnis.
Wenn ich meine gelähmten Beine
oder Arme sehe,
finde ich das z.T.
schon eher etwas abstossend.
Aber das gehört jetzt halt dazu.
So ist es jetzt halt.
Ich kann es nicht ändern.
Ich lasse mich deswegen
nicht wütend machen.
Werden die Spastiken
und der Schmerz zu heftig,
bringt ein Joint
vorübergehend etwas Erleichterung.
Franziska ist Präsidentin
des Medical Cannabis Clubs Zürich
und setzt sich dafür ein,
dass Kranke und Behinderte
Cannabis legal konsumieren
und in geprüfter Qualität
beziehen können.
Wie viel Gras ist noch übrig, Mami?
Ja, es hat schon noch ...
- Zeig mal.
Ich brauche vielleicht
schon noch mal.
Vielleicht noch für eine Woche.
Dann nimm doch nochmals. Dann müssen
wir nicht nochmals gehen.
Das haben Sie sich früher
wohl nicht erträumen lassen,
dass Sie mal Joints füllen.
Joints füllen
für eine meiner Töchter, genau.
Ich habe immer erzählt,
was das für ein Teufelszeug sei.
Aber ja ...
Sie kann es nicht selber.
Darum machen wir das halt.
Ich habe selber
noch nie einen geraucht.
Aber ich muss es vielleicht
doch mal noch probieren.
Wer weiss.
Die Finca der Quadris liegt
mitten in einer Bananenplantage.
Und ist rollstuhlgängig.
Ein kleines Stück Freiheit
für die Tetraplegikerin.
Es macht schon Spass,
etwas allein zu machen
und niemanden bei mir zu haben.
Aber das Risiko besteht immer,
dass ich nicht mehr weiterkomme
und mir niemand helfen kann.
Aber jemand
würde schon vorbeikommen.
Früher oder später.
Die Insel hat Franziska verändert.
In all dem Schmerz keimt eine neue,
zarte Zuversicht auf.
Ich fühle mich
schon ein bisschen anders,
ein bisschen mehr,
wie ich früher war.
Nicht mehr so ... ziellos.
Eine Weile lang habe ich den Tag
einfach so genommen,
wie er gekommen ist, und mir
keine grossen Gedanken gemacht.
Jetzt hat sich das
schon ein bisschen verändert.
Das ist schon ein Zeichen, dass ich
wieder im Leben angekommen bin.
Ich habe mich mit der Situation
so zurechtgefunden,
dass ich wirklich
einen Schritt weitergehen kann
und vielleicht doch noch irgend-
welche Träume verwirklichen kann.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die in Teneriffa gewonnene Zuversicht
ist Franziska
all die Jahre erhalten geblieben.
Noch immer setzt sie sich stark
für eine straffreie
medizinische Verwendung
von Cannabis ein.
Es mangle an Verständnis für das
medizinische Potenzial der Pflanze.
Eine Freundin
hat für mich recherchiert,
was gegen Spastik helfen könnte.
In Nottwil sassen alle
abends draussen und rauchten Joints.
Da habe ich
eins und eins zusammengezählt.
Ich fand, ich probiere das auch.
Ich stellte fest, dass das das
Schmerzmittel war, das ich brauche.
Ich habe es auch den Ärzten erzählt.
Ich sagte: "Hey, das ist das,
was ich brauche. Das hilft mir."
Aber es ist leider
immer noch verboten
und es ist nicht einfach, das so
zu bekommen, wie ich es brauche.
Merkst du es auch psychisch?
Wenn du nun mit mir redest,
bist du eine andere als die,
die im Bett mit mir geredet hat?
- Nein, ich bin einfach entspannt.
Ich habe kein High-Gefühl mehr,
keinen Flash. Überhaupt nicht.
Das ist die Substanz, bei der ich
am wenigsten einen Flash habe.
Ich hatte ganz viele verschiedene
Schmerzmittel von Ärzten
und ich war z.T. so zugedröhnt.
Ich fühlte mich extrem unwohl.
Und mit Cannabis habe ich das nicht.
Welche Teile deines Körpers
spürst du jetzt?
Ich spüre meinen ganzen Körper.
Das überrascht die Leute immer.
Sie denken, bei einer Lähmung
spürt man nichts mehr.
Ich weiss genau,
wo meine Füsse und Hände sind.
Wenn jemand sagt:
"Ich durchtrenne dein Rückenmark,
dann spürst du nichts mehr
und hast keine Schmerzen mehr",
das würde ich nicht wollen.
Ich bin total froh,
dass ich meinen Körper noch spüre
und Zugang zu meinem Körper habe.
Ich kann mir
schlichtweg nicht vorstellen,
wie es ist, wenn man
seine Beine nicht mehr spürt.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Es gibt bestimmt Menschen,
die denken:
"Ich würde lieber
gar nicht mehr leben,
als in so einem Körper
gefangen zu sein."
Das dachte ich auch.
Ich weiss noch ...
Der Schwager meines damaligen Chefs
hatte einen Unfall
und wurde Tetraplegiker.
Da sprachen wir im Geschäft
über dieses Thema.
Wir fanden auch, dass wir so
nicht leben wollen würden.
Das Problem ist, dass man
gar nicht an den Punkt kommt,
an dem man darüber entscheiden kann,
ob man das will.
Dir wird das Leben gerettet
und wenn du wieder aufwachst,
heisst es:
"Du bist jetzt Tetraplegiker."
Wenn du dann findest,
dass du so nicht leben willst,
musst du aktiv dein Leben beenden.
Du kennst Leute,
die sich so entschieden.
Ja, ich habe drei Freunde, die sich
gegen das Leben mit Schmerzen
im Rollstuhl entschieden haben.
Es braucht total viel,
um einen solchen Schritt zu machen.
Dein Verhältnis zu deinem Körper
hat sich innerhalb eines Tages
komplett verändert.
Vor und nach deinem Unfall.
Was für ein Verhältnis
hast du jetzt zu deinem Körper?
Jetzt wieder ein besseres.
Aber ich habe ihn
ganz lange gehasst.
Ich hatte gar keine Beziehung mehr
zu meinem Körper.
Ich lehnte ihn ab. Ich konnte mich
fast nicht mehr anschauen.
Mich selber im Spiegel zu sehen,
war am Anfang total schlimm.
Ich habe das eher vermieden.
Diese gelähmten Arme und Beine,
und die Art,
wie sich der Körper verändert ...
Die Füsse werden krumm, die Hände
komisch und verkrampft und verdreht.
Der Bauch wird immer dicker, weil
man keine Bauchmuskulatur mehr hat.
Nichts hält mehr zusammen.
Ich fand es schrecklich,
mich anzuschauen.
Es ist sehr schwer, das anzunehmen.
Nimmst du dich noch als Frau wahr?
Im Sinn von ...
... anziehend für Männer ...
Hast du diesen Teil noch für dich?
Ganz lang hatte ich das nicht mehr.
Ich hatte lange das Gefühl, dass
Männer mich nicht mehr anschauen.
Hast du dich wie ein "Es" gefühlt?
Auch mit dem Rollstuhl.
Die Leute reagieren
schon anders auf einen als früher.
Früher spürte ich
die Reaktionen der Männer auch.
Mit dem Rollstuhl merkte man,
dass das nicht mehr da war.
Aber da haben mir
Social Media etwas geholfen.
Dort bekomme ich
viele positive Reaktionen.
Ich realisierte: "Nein, du bist
immer noch eine schöne Frau."
"Du gefällst auch den Männern noch."
Das tat mir gut, und es veränderte
meine eigene Sicht auf mich.
Du hast gesagt, etwas,
das du dir wieder wünschen würdest,
sei eine Beziehung.
Wie weit bist du da schon?
Eigentlich immer noch nicht so weit.
Aber das wäre schon
immer noch ein Traum.
Ich hätte schon gerne
jemanden an meiner Seite,
der bereit ist,
das etwas umständliche Leben
in Kauf zu nehmen.
Ich habe jetzt ja gemerkt,
dass ich in der Männerwelt
nicht so schlecht ankomme.
Ich denke, ich habe schon Optionen,
in Zukunft jemanden zu finden.
Yves Bossart, wir haben vorher schon
übers Thema Körper gesprochen.
Häufig denken wir ans Aussehen,
wenn wir von einem Körper sprechen.
Aber das, was wir eben
bei Frau Quadri gesehen haben,
dass der Körper das Haus ist,
in dem die Seele wohnt -
das merkt man immer erst,
wenn er nicht mehr funktioniert.
Warum ist das so?
- Hm.
Weil wir uns an vieles gewöhnen,
würde ich sagen.
Erst wenn man krank ist, schätzt
man wieder den Wert der Gesundheit.
Das ist beim Körper auch so.
Wir neigen dazu,
in eine Blase zu kommen
und den Luxus, dass wir gesund sind,
als selbstverständlich zu sehen.
Erst, wenn wir mit solchen
Geschichten konfrontiert sind ...
... spüren wir, dass das etwas ist,
wofür wir dankbar sein sollten.
Etwas, was mich im Gespräch mit ihr
sehr beschäftigt hat,
ist, wie sie beschreibt, wie sie
von anderen wahrgenommen wird.
Was macht das mit uns, wenn
ein Körper anders als die Norm ist?
Viele Leute, deren Körper
aus der Norm fällt, beschreiben das.
Das Auf-etwas-reduziert-werden.
Dort müssen wir uns selber
an der Nase nehmen
und uns fragen,
wie das für die Person ist,
wenn jede Begegnung
mit diesem Blick, mit Mitleid,
vielleicht auch mit Ekel anfängt.
Das muss unglaublich hart sein.
Und die Reduktion
einer ganzen Person auf den Körper.
Wir sprachen vorher
über die sozialen Medien
und die Bilderflut
von optimierten Körpern.
Das ist tief in uns drin. Deshalb
reagieren wir zuerst irritiert.
Aber ich glaube,
es findet ein Wandel statt,
hin zur Diversity,
zur Diversität,
zur Vielfalt von Körperbildern
und Körpernormen.
Das ist eine gute, befreiende,
emanzipative Entwicklung.
Es gibt Menschen,
die nur zu gut wissen, wie es ist,
wenn man wegen des eigenen Körpers
diskriminiert wird.
Melanie Dellenbach
und Andrea Vollgas gehören dazu.
Sie wurden schon als Kind
wegen ihres Körpers gemobbt.
Sie setzen sich beide
auf recht unterschiedliche Art
für eine Gesellschaft ein,
in der alle Körper okay sind.
* Lockere Musik *
Wie sagt man es richtig?
Etwas mehr auf den Hüften?
Wohlgenährt? Schwergewichtig?
Oder ganz einfach dick?
Ich habe das Wort "dick",
oder auf Englisch "fat",
für mich zurückerobert.
Das ist wie das Wort "queer",
das früher eine Beleidigung war.
Das hat man zurückerobert und sagt:
"Ja, das bin ich, und das ist okay."
So nimmt man dem die Kraft,
dass das Wort als Beleidigung
gebraucht werden kann.
Melanie Dellenbach,
37 Jahre, Mutter einer Tochter,
Pflegefachfrau
und sog. Fettaktivistin.
Als solche hat sie der Dicken-
feindlichkeit den Kampf angesagt.
Die Idee, dass dicke Menschen
einfach ein bisschen mehr
dünn sein wollen müssten,
und dann würde es funktionieren ...
Das ist etwas Hartnäckiges.
Das Problem ist auch
der Vergleich zu Leuten,
die, sagen wir,
ein nicht so schönes Gesicht haben,
die aus diesem Grund
als weniger schön beurteilt werden.
So wird bei dicken Leuten
immer gleich noch ein Urteil
über die Moral
dieser Person gefällt.
D.h., diese Person
ist undiszipliniert, sie ist faul,
sie ist vielleicht auch ungebildet.
Die weiss nicht, was richtiges
Schweizer Essen und Bewegung ist.
Melanie hat den Schritt
an die Öffentlichkeit gewagt,
um anderen dicken Menschen
Mut zu machen.
Sie setzt sich
gegen Gewichtsdiskriminierung
und für mehr Akzeptanz ein.
Häufig würden Mehrgewichtige
von der Gesellschaft
als problematisch
oder krank angesehen.
Fatshaming, gerade auch im Netz,
ist weit verbreitet.
Wenn ich das immer wieder
höre oder lese,
was manche Leute für böse, fiese,
abwertende Dinge schreiben ...
Manchmal denke ich:
"Warum tue ich mir das an?"
Man sollte über keinen Menschen
so schreiben.
Bodyshaming zum Trotz:
Immer mehr dicke Influencerinnen
präsentieren selbstbewusst
ihre Plus-Size-Körper.
Selbstvermarktung? Klar.
Aber es geht auch um Sichtbarkeit
und Vernetzung.
Mein Name ist Andrea Vollgas.
Und ich bin ... Ah! Lesbisch!
Yes! Und dick! Und Künstlerin!
Ist halt so.
Und ich mache eben so Kram.
So Kram und so Kram.
Und so Kram.
In einem Video
labelst du dich als "Dicke". Warum?
Weil ich dick bin.
Ich werde von der Gesellschaft
als dick angesehen.
Ich habe die Erfahrungen
einer dicken Person gemacht.
Ich bin nicht sehr dick. Das stimmt.
Viele Diskriminierungen,
die sehr dicke Menschen erfahren,
erfahre ich nicht.
Ich bin nicht eingeschränkt
in irgendeiner Form,
wenn ich im Flugzeug sitze usw.
Das ist nicht so.
Da bin ich noch privilegiert.
Nichtsdestotrotz bin ich dick
und werde als dick gesehen.
Es gibt nicht nur Standardkörper.
Mit ihren Illustrationen
zeigt die Künstlerin Andrea Vollgas,
wie vielfältig und divers
Menschen sind.
Ihr Ziel:
das Bild in unseren Köpfen zu ändern.
Das darf man auch alles sehen.
Laut Bundesamt für Gesundheit
ist Übergewicht eine Volkskrankheit.
In der Schweiz, so die Studien,
sind 42 % der Erwachsenen
übergewichtig,
was eine Herausforderung
für das Gesundheitssystem darstelle.
Es ist ein Angriff
auf jede Person, die dick ist.
Wenn wir
von solchen Zahlen reden ...
... von solchen grossen Zahlen
reden, dann kann es nicht sein,
dass wir im Endeffekt
auf die einzelne Person achten
und sagen: "Du bist schuld, weil du
nicht auf dein Gewicht achtest."
Dann müssen wir
langsam anfangen zu schauen,
wo das grosse Problem steckt.
Wo ist die Ursache des Ganzen?
Und das wird bis heute
einfach noch nicht diskutiert.
Macht das Schuldgefühle?
Nein, ich finde,
das ist ganz einfach falsch.
Man kann nicht die Schuld
der Pharma, des Systems
und der explodierenden
Gesundheitskosten
dicken Menschen aufbürden. Punkt.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass du dort hinten Hosen hast.
Ja. Hier sind noch mehr Kleider.
- Die schaue ich mir nachher an.
Seit sie aufgehört habe,
sich mit Diäten zu malträtieren,
sei sie gesund.
Es sei ein langer Weg gewesen,
sich anzunehmen
und den Körper zu akzeptieren.
Geholfen habe ihr u.a.
ihre Leidenschaft für Mode.
Ein wichtiger Teil
war auch das Entdecken
von Fashionblogs
über grosse Grössen.
Dann fing ich selber an,
Fotos auf einem Blog zu teilen.
So kam ich in die sog. Fettosphäre,
diese Blogging-Szene.
So lernte ich auch
Fettaktivismus kennen.
Das war ein langer Prozess.
Toll!
- Ja, nicht? Was meinst du?
Das ist cool, nicht?
Ich habe meine Kleider drunter an.
Es ist schön lang.
Vielleicht ein My kürzer.
Oder höhere Schuhe.
Eine Gesellschaft, die sich
am perfekten Körper orientiert,
schlank und durchtrainiert,
macht es dicken Menschen
nicht eben leicht.
Das Problem
der Gewichtsdiskriminierung
erleben viele von ihnen
in allen Lebensbereichen.
Für Andrea kein Grund für Rückzug,
sondern: volle Pulle.
Ihr Schlüssel zum Glück:
Selbstakzeptanz.
Irgendwann habe ich einfach gemerkt:
Wenn ich nicht tue,
was für mich gut ist
und was für mich richtig ist,
dann stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Weshalb soll ich mich
mein Leben lang verstecken?
Für mich ist es wichtig zu sagen:
"Ich bin hier,
ich bin da, ich bin sichtbar."
Die anderen müssen damit umgehen,
dass ich da bin.
Ich muss mich nicht
für alle anderen verstecken.
In dem Moment habe ich geschnallt:
Ich darf einen Bikini tragen.
Als Kind trug ich ein Badeanzug
und ein langes T-Shirt,
mindestens bis zu den Knien.
Den Badeanzug bloss abdecken,
nur nicht gesehen werden.
Immer brav allem folgen.
Man möchte ja auch reinpassen.
Genügt Selbstliebe?
Oder muss gesellschaftlich
mehr gehen?
Im Kampf
gegen unrealistische Körperideale
trifft Melanie Gleichgesinnte.
Hier, an dieser Veranstaltung
von Pink Apple,
reden Künstlerinnen und Aktivistinnen
über das Thema Körperrespekt
und erzählen auf der Bühne, was sie
im Alltag diesbezüglich erleben.
Mein Partner hat mal gesagt, dass
unser Kind Stigmatisierung erlebt,
weil ich eine dicke Mutter bin.
Und das ist genau das.
Im Kindergarten
haben die Lehrpersonen eine Idee ...
... wer wir als Familie sind,
also ungebildet usw.
Weil die Mutter ist ja dick.
Das ist dann nochmals ...
Ich selber kann mich gut wehren.
Aber für das Kind ...
Ich muss schauen, dass das Kind
möglichst unkompliziert
durch die Schulkarriere kommt,
weil einfach genauer geschaut wird.
Wie fühlt man sich
in seinem Körper wohl?
Seit gut zehn Jahren
ist Andrea mit Dunja liiert.
Beide haben sich stark mit ihrem
Erscheinungsbild auseinandergesetzt.
Voilà!
- Vielen Dank!
Das ist total lecker.
Willst du probieren?
Den gesellschaftlichen Erwartungen
zu trotzen sei ein Befreiungsschlag.
Mein Göttibub
hat mich immer wieder gefragt:
"Gotti, bist du eigentlich
ein Mann oder eine Frau?"
Am Anfang fühlte ich mich verletzt.
Ich dachte, das sieht man doch.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Am Anfang sagte ich:
"Ich bin doch klar eine Frau."
Das brachte mich zum Nachdenken
und machte mir bewusst,
dass ich mich in manchen Situationen
als Mann fühle.
Damit zu spielen, wenn es mir gerade
passt, hat mir Freiheiten gegeben.
Es geht nicht immer nur darum,
wie dick oder dünn der Körper ist,
sondern auch darum,
wie man sich darstellt
bzw. wie man wahrgenommen wird.
Was ist schön?
Das ist sehr relativ.
Und jeder Mensch sieht das
aus seiner eigenen Perspektive.
Und ja, das ist sehr befreiend.
* Lockere Musik *
Wann wurde das Aussehen
deines Körpers ein Thema?
Als ich
ungefähr acht, neun Jahre alt war.
Das Krasse ist, dass ganz viele
weiblich sozialisierte Menschen
das erleben: Wenn sie zehn sind,
bekommen sie die ersten Bemerkungen.
Die hast du auch bekommen?
- Völlig.
Wir sassen an einem Tisch.
Und jemand sagte: "Bei Melanie
müssen wir langsam schauen."
Die Person neben mir
tätschelte meinen Bauch und sagte:
"Du bekommst ein Bäuchlein."
Das war eine Bekannte der Familie.
Ich weiss noch ganz genau,
wie ich mich geschämt habe.
Dieser Moment ist mir in Erinnerung.
Viele Menschen erzählen mir, dass
sie auch solche Momente erlebten.
So wurde ihnen klar,
dass irgendetwas mit ihnen
falsch war, nicht richtig war.
Ich bin nicht so, wie ich sein soll.
Es ist ja nicht so,
als ob das eine Wahl wäre.
Ich habe mich ja nicht
mit zehn entschlossen:
"So, ich werde jetzt dick!
Das ist jetzt halt so."
"Das ist jetzt mein Lebensziel."
Aber das ist genau der Vorwurf.
Implizit hat man immer das Gefühl,
ihr hättet die Wahl.
Wenn ihr euch Mühe gäbet,
könntet ihr anders aussehen.
Das bekommen wir
seit Jahrzehnten beigebracht.
Iss etwas weniger!
Bewege dich etwas mehr!
Dann wirst du dünn werden.
Das ist einfach nicht so.
Sonst wären die meisten dicken
Menschen schon lange straight-sized.
Ich habe sehr lange
mit meinem Körper gekämpft.
Ich habe auch jede Diät auf
des Menschen Erdenplaneten versucht.
Das Problem war nicht,
dass ich dick oder dünn war.
Das Problem war, dass mein Körper
nicht in Ordnung war.
Alle wollten mich
in irgendeiner Form verändern.
Ich brauchte sehr lange,
um zu verstehen,
dass dieses Bild
nicht mir entspricht.
Das hat angefangen,
als ich mich geoutet habe.
Als ich realisiert habe,
dass da noch etwas anderes ist.
Vielleicht sind es
doch nicht die Männer.
Ich habe mich
erst nach meinem Outing
mit dieser Körpergeschichte
auseinandergesetzt.
Die Akzeptanz kam erst,
als ich mich damit beschäftigte.
Wie war das bei dir, Melanie?
- Das war eine lange Zeitspanne.
Ich brauchte mehrere Jahre.
Ich habe auch ein
therapeutisches Coaching gemacht.
U.a. habe ich dort gelernt,
hinzuschauen.
Dieses Thema ...
Einerseits aus diesen
extremen Diäten auszusteigen
und einfach mal essen.
Also regelmässig essen,
ausgewogen essen.
Und sonst hinzuschauen.
Mal zu schauen: Wer bin ich?
Was mache ich überhaupt gerne?
Was wäre, wenn ich nicht mehr
das Ziel "dünn werden" verfolgte?
Sondern einfach mal leben würde?
Zu sagen:
"Hey, ich bin so, wie ich bin."
"Und ich habe ein Recht,
mit Respekt behandelt zu werden."
Wo findet
diese Diskriminierung statt?
Gewichtsdiskriminierung
passiert überall.
Es gibt keinen Ort,
an dem sie nicht vorkommt.
Man wird angejohlt,
Sprüche und Bemerkungen kommen.
Oft ist es verknüpft damit,
dass wir dicke Frauen sind.
Das hat immer auch
mit dem Frausein zu tun.
Es ist eine Mischung aus Sexismus
und Dickenfeindlichkeit.
Ich habe letzthin
ein wunderbares Beispiel erlebt.
Das passiert
sehr vielen dicken Menschen.
Ich war beim Frauenarzt.
Ich war vollkommen gesund.
Alles war in Ordnung.
Dann wollte sie mir
ungefragt einreden,
dass ich
in eine Klinik gehen soll ...
Also, ob ich nicht
in eine Klinik gehen möchte
und mich medikamentös behandeln
lassen wolle, um abzunehmen.
Ja. Und solche Dinge passieren oft.
Das ist nicht selten.
Was muss passieren,
damit diese Vielfalt an Körpern
besser gelebt werden kann,
damit alle Körper in unserer Gesell-
schaft akzeptiert werden können?
Wir müssen als Menschen
umstellen und akzeptieren,
dass es verschiedene Körper,
verschiedene Gender,
verschiedene Menschen gibt.
Was braucht es, damit wir das können?
- Dass es keine Normen mehr gibt.
Das ist das grösste Problem.
Dass wir das Gefühl haben,
wir müssten Menschen korrigieren,
die nicht in dieses Normbild passen.
Dass man die picken müsste und sagt:
"So hast du es besser zu machen."
Wieso nicht erlauben,
dass Vielfalt da ist?
Und wenn man jemanden sieht,
einfach die Klappe halten.
Seine Meinung
einfach für sich behalten.
Für sich behalten.
Man muss es nicht aussprechen,
auch wenn man es denkt.
Das nehmen wir sicher so mit.
Vielen Dank.
Noch ein inspirierendes Gespräch
zum Schluss dieser Sendung.
Merci vielmals, Andrea Vollgas,
vielen Dank, Melanie Dellenbach.
Forza, für alles,
wofür ihr weiterhin kämpft.
Danke.
- Vielen Dank.
Mehr Respekt für alle Arten von Körpern.
Das wäre super.
Wir würden alle davon profitieren.
Aber es fängt vor allem bei sich selbst an.
Darum: Was hast du für eine Beziehung
zu deinem Körper?
Fühlst du dich easy damit,
oder ist es eher ein ständiger Kampf?
Schreib es hier in die Kommentare!